welcome to the video on implicit
differentiation implicit differentiation
so let's say that i have well let's just
explain the difference between implicit
and explicit first so if i had a
function that was let's say y
is equal to i don't know x squared
plus 2x
plus 3.
in this situation
y the variable y is defined explicitly
in terms of x how do i know that well if
you give me an x i can just input it
into this expression right there and i
explicitly get y right it just it just
pops out of the equation
but on the other hand what if i had
something like this what if i had
x squared
plus y squared is equal to
a hundred
well now if i give you an x
you still can figure out a y but it's
just not as easy right you would if i
said x is equal to i don't know x is
equal to
9 you would put 9 in here you would get
81 plus y squared is equal to 100
you would subtract that from so you get
y squared is equal to what 19. i don't
know if these numbers are weird and then
you get y is equal to the plus or minus
square root of 19.
right so you still could
solve for y but you have to but this
expression right here or this equation
defined y
implicitly you know that's a different
you know when people use the word
explicit or implicit in everyday
language it's the same thing when you
say you know he explicitly said this
that means you know
i am hungry i explicitly stated that i
am hungry but you could implicitly state
that you're hungry you could say oh well
you know i haven't eaten for a long time
and you know boy would be nice to maybe
eat something and that would be kind of
an implicit expression of your hunger
because someone would have to kind of do
a little bit of work to come to the
conclusion that you're hungry instead of
you telling them so with that out of the
way let's actually do some
differentiation
so what everything you've learned about
differentiation right now has been
explicit differentiation so example in
this
for this function
we know how to take the explicit
derivative here well it's explicitly
defined function so we just take the
derivative we apply the derivative
operator we take we take the rate of
change of both sides of this equation
with respect to x so you could do it
like this
we're taking the derivative operator i
know this is getting messy we're taking
the derivative operator on that side
and we're also taking the derivative
operator on this side i know that i
didn't plan to write that there that's
why
so what it happens on the left side the
rate of change at y changes with respect
to x well we just write that the rate of
change of y for every small change in y
what is this change in x
that equals
and then we know how to do this this
this type of derivative this is just a a
simple quadratic so that equals 2x
plus 2 plus 0 right so there we do we
just did some explicit differentiation
so how do we do the same thing here well
we're going to do the same thing we're
going to apply the derivative operator
to both sides of this equation
so let me do that i'll do that in a
different color let me erase all of this
too because this is kind of
obvious things that you might already
know
let me erase all of that
okay so i'll take the derivative
operator to both sides of this equation
so this is no different than what we did
up here
and as you learned in algebra anything
you do to one side of equation you have
to do to the other side of the equation
otherwise it would no longer be an
equation
take the derivative operator because
we're taking the derivative with respect
to x we could have taken it with respect
to y
of x squared
plus
y
squared is equal to if you take the
derivative of both sides right
this
derivative
100 with respect to x right
so this equals
the derivative
with respect to x
let me put in brackets i was going to do
parentheses but i think
of x squared plus the derivative with
respect to x
of y squared
and what's the derivative with respect
to x of a hundred for every change in x
how much does this change well it
doesn't change at all it's going to stay
a hundred right so this is zero the
derivative of a constant really respect
to any changing variable is going to be
zero so that was just 0.
and what's the derivative of x squared
with respect to x
well we did that up here right when we
took this derivative we just took the
derivative of each of these terms the
derivative of x squared with respect to
x well that's just 2x
so we get 2x
plus now this x this term here
is where you might get a little bit
confused
i am taking
the derivative of y squared
with respect to x the derivative of y
squared with respect to x so let me take
you on a side and you don't you
shouldn't do this every time that you do
one of these
implicit differentiation problems but
i'm doing this because i want you to
understand what we're doing so let's say
i just defined
g
is equal to
y squared
right so let's say this this was g
and i want to take the derivative of g
with respect to x so i apply the
derivative operator on both sides of
this
so let me do that so
the derivative
d
of x on that side
that's a d
there you go so what we get is
the derivative
of g
with respect to x is equal to
the derivative with respect to x of y
squared
right and so far we haven't really done
much i've just rewrote things
but what does the chain rule tell us
what does the chain rule tell us the
chain rule tells us
that the derivative let me stay in the
same color i was switching colors
the derivative
of any variable with respect to x
with respect to another variable is
equal to the derivative of g
with respect to y
times the derivative of y
with respect to x
and you could view this
if you don't have the full intuition of
the chain rule yet there's a couple of
ways to view it you know all of these
dg's and dys that you see
throughout the integral and and
differential calculus all these really
mean are really really really really
small change in g a really really really
small change in y a really really small
change in x so you can almost view these
so you know if you have a when you
multiply this out this really really
small change in y is the same as this
really really small change in y so if
these were these are essentially
fractions so you could cancel these out
and that's why you would get the
derivative of the change in g with
respect to x or the derivative of g with
respect to x
so this is what the chain rule tells us
so given that this is what the chain
rule tells us
how does that help us figuring out this
well we know that the derivative of g
with respect to x is equal to the
derivative of g with respect to y
well we already know that g is equal to
y squared i just made that definition
that's where we started from so what's
the derivative of g with respect to y
well that's just 2y
right just using our our derivative
rules or our polynomial rules which
hopefully you believe actually work
because there are several videos where i
where we prove it
and then
times the derivative of y with respect
to x
which we don't know and that's actually
kind of what we're what we're going to
try to try to solve for
so the derivative of g with respect to x
is 2y times the derivative of y with
respect to x well g is just the same
thing as y squared right so the
derivative of this is g and you don't
you know normally when you do this you
don't have to go through the whole
problem of substituting for g i just
wanted to give you that intuition so
what's this derivative right here
well it's going to be the derivative of
this expression with respect to y from
the chain rule so that's 2y
times the
derivative of y with respect to x
is equal to 0.
when you do it mechanically it's
actually quite simple you know you just
say oh well let me pretend like y is
like an x take a derivative and i
multiply it times the derivative of y
with respect to x mechanically it's very
simple but i really want you to
understand that intuition that this is
coming out of the chain rule and
actually the chain rule itself is not
this you know bizarre concept it's
really you're just multiplying fractions
so let me clear up some space here and
we can finish this problem and then i'll
do a problem where you have to do
implicit differentiation and even in
this one that i just gave it's really
useful to do implicit differentiation
so
let me
i could clear this guy out up here
clear that out
i could clear all of this stuff out
there we go clear all of that out
ready to do some more work
so now we can solve this for the
derivative of y with respect to x so we
get let's subtract 2x from both sides so
we get
y
sorry oh yeah 2y d y
dx is equal to i'm just subtracting 2x
from both sides minus 2x
and then what do we get we get
dy
over dx is equal to divide both sides by
2y the 2s cancel out you get minus
x
over y
and this is interesting just just as it
is right because what was this this was
the equation for a circle with
with radius 10 right you know r squared
and if you know your trigonometry and
all of that
this tells you that the that the the the
slope of a circle at any point is equal
to the negative of the x over the y well
we you know we know from trigonometry
that the x is the cosine and the y is
the sign and so that tells you something
interesting about how the derivative is
related to the tangent and all of that
but anyway i won't go into that we're
just learning implicit differentiation
here but it's sometimes fun to just
think about things
so how is this different from everything
else we've learned so far well here we
have the derivative the the derivative
is actually a function
of both the x
and the y value and if we feel really
uncomfortable
having this y here
if we don't like that
what we could do is we can substitute so
let's solve for y here we get y
y squared is equal to 100
minus x squared and then you get y is
equal to the plus or minus square root
of 100 minus x squared and so you just
substitute that in here
so you get another way of writing the
derivative of y with respect to x
sometimes you'll see y prime
i'm just switching notation just
familiar with it is equal to
minus
x over the plus or minus square root
of 100 minus x squared and to some
degree since we have plus or minus down
here
this minus sign it kind of doesn't
matter right because when it's a minus
here it becomes a plus when it's plus
it's minus so you can kind of ignore
this that's something that's something
interesting for you to think about as
well but anyway
and and this was interesting because our
our traditional way of solving
derivatives
we had never seen a plus or minus here
so that that might be a little bit
interesting to you so now let's do a
problem that is actually a bit of a
trick problem
it's not a trick problem but it's it's
actually something that i think
i i when did i i first saw it either
when i was practicing for the ap
calculus exam or actually saw it on the
ap calculus exam so it's something that
you might encounter but it's really neat
let's say i have y
is equal to x
to the x
so at first you say oh this looks easy
maybe i could use the power rule but no
chain rule but i have two x's here and i
mean you might want to just pause and
think about this for a little bit
because this actually isn't that
straightforward a problem and even
though right here y is explicitly
defined in terms of x right if i give
you x if i say x is 3 well then y is 3
to the third y is 27. so this is an
explicit function i've explicitly
defined y in terms of x but it's very
hard to differentiate explicitly
and here's the trick
let's take the natural log or actually
you could take any logarithm but let's
take the natural log of both sides of
this equation
so you get
the natural log
of y
is equal to the natural log
of x to the x
and why did i do that
because now i can use what we know about
logarithm properties we know that
you know we know that log of a to the b
is equal to b log of a
and you could watch the exponent
properties videos if you forgot that
so let's
rewrite this like like using this
property and i'm going to switch colors
so we get
we get the natural log of y is equal to
x times the natural log
of x
and now we can implicitly differentiate
this
so what's so let's take the derivative
with respect to x of both sides of this
equation and i'll switch colors again
nope that's not what i wanted to do
d dx and i'm writing this just because
just so you know what i'm doing
is equal to d
dx
of x natural log of x
so the derivative of this expression
with respect to x is equal to the
derivative of this respect expression
with respect to y times the derivative
of y with respect to x so what's
the derivative of this with respect to y
well it's 1 over y
1 over y
times the derivative just the chain rule
times the derivative of y with respect
to x
d y d x
is equal to and remember just
mechanically if you want to you know
make sure you're doing it right you just
take the derivative with respect to y
and you multiply it times d y d x that's
just the chain rule
time equals and now we take the
derivative of this well now we can just
use the product rule the derivative of
the first right it's this times this so
what's the derivative of x it's 1
so it's 1 times the natural log of x
plus the derivative of the second term
1 over x times the first term times x
let me clear that up there
i'm already over time but i've become a
youtube partner so my videos can be
longer
but i don't want to make them too long
because you'll get bored
all right
so let's simplify this we get
we get one over y
d y
d x is equal to
the natural log of x
plus well that just cancels out and
becomes 1 right
and so we have the derivative
of y with respect to x is equal to y
i'm just multiplying both sides of this
equation times y
y times the natural log of x plus 1.
now you might say you're done but some
people just don't like it the the change
of y with respect to x they don't like
it being defined in terms of y so let's
substitute we know that y is equal to x
is equal to x to the x
so that equals
that equals
x to the x
times the natural log of x plus 1.
so another way of saying it is that y
prime or the change in y with respect to
x or the slope at any point of this
curve is equal to
x to the x
natural log of x
plus x to the x i just distributed the x
to the x but that's pretty neat this is
kind of a you know a five-star problem
that you might see in your books and you
might see it in a math competition and
people will be really impressed and it'd
be even more impressive if you kind of
recognize this pattern and you're able
to find the anti-derivative of it and
recognize that it is x to the x anyway
i've talked for too long i will see you
in the next video